présente-toi termignone quoi ton truc à
toi que j'ai beaucoup de chance si la
chance est pas un super pouvoir
messi mais non les choses finissent
toujours bien
ouah mais c'est pas super pouvoirs s'ils
sont nés
ça
on coupe la poire en deux on n'a qu'à
dire non à recaser qu'est ce que j'ai
comme chose
wedde ton coeur est juste si tu
t'entraînes toi aussi tu peux être x man
x men c'est pas ma canne mais alors pas
du tout parce que tout d'abord on m'a
déjà des puces clé je le protégerai
contre câbles mais tout seul je peux pas
je suis à x man ta gueule tu as tout et
cee-lo green beaver talus et a prises
pour justin bieber est prêt on dit qu'un
bouffon déguisé en jouant tellement
d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas l'univers dc
comics
[Musique]
la bagnole vous êtes le boss des bosses
pas faux la désinvolture l'attitude les
cuisses en acier la plus jolie des
fiasson
je suis en retard j'étais en train de
rassembler toutes britten de la terre
pour le propulser dans l'espace où il
pourra continuer à ne rien faire le mois
l'appel de ma vie c'est quoi ce délire
je m'appelle câble je viens sur ce gosse
quoi quel gosse du pouce ou tu crèves
les enfants nous rendent un peu meilleur
que ce qu'on est
il a besoin de toi ou alors toi tu es
plus vite et que j'en r je ne serais pas
capable tout est ce qu a marre
et j'y arriverai pas seul mec informé à
groupe de la mort qui tue et voilà notre
gros fura progressiste
paritaire est connue sous le nom de
[Musique]
x force ça sent le réchauffé c'est moi
excellente remarque est maintenant
musique
au mois d'août ils ont bien chauffé le
ralenti la justice c'est pas toujours
propre et si tu veux te battre pour le
bien parfois faute salir les doigts
le sign on pour hommes est à cette
génération ce que la coupe mulet était
aux années 80 c'est là que je m'en veux
d'avoir arrêté les études on va
satisfaire les attentes mais genre grave
plus de raison de faire 1 3 on aurait
tort d'essayer bon s'arrête aux deux
essais du riz
[Musique]